welcome back to new rockstars it's me mt
and did you know that there was a loki
easter egg hidden within multiverse of
madness that pretty much everybody
missed yeah they actually put the entire
secret timeline in multiverse of madness
but i don't think anyone noticed but i
did because i'm a weirdo without a life
and a girlfriend it's been two very long
years
[Music]
so let me show you where that sneaky ass
sam raimi put that [ __ ] real quick
because it's actually quite clever and
it helps us understand the entire mcu
cosmic hierarchy as a whole but before
we do that make sure you head on over to
newrockstarsmerch.com so you can pick up
our latest obsession shirts inspired by
thor love and thunder it's an amazing
shirt but it's not going to last forever
so head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com immediately so you
can buy you a nice four shirt today also
our new thor hats because they're pretty
cool alright so the sacred timeline of
multiverse madness appears during that
trippy sequence of stephen and america
tumbling through the multiverse in a
very nauseating fashion specifically
towards the beginning of that sequence
check it out
stop you see that glowy [ __ ] right there
that's super secret glowy [ __ ] branching
off in crazy ways inside of this black
hole doesn't that look familiar doesn't
that look like something that marvel
literally showed us at the beginning of
the loki finale play that clip for the
audience joshua
[Music]
yeah that's because the beginning of the
loki finale literally showed us the
exact location of the citadel at the end
of time by zooming inside of the
supermassive black hole that has formed
at the very end of time in the mcu
itself like i've said many times in the
past especially during my video on the
marvel trigger theory that i always
bring up where i literally brought this
exact thing that i'm telling you up
months ago because as i said many times
in the past marvel studios has crafted
their entire cinematic universe around
scientific fact in theory and scientists
in real life actually theorize that
towards the end of our universe's life
there is going to be a period of the end
of the universe called the black hole
era where all the energy and matter that
has ever existed in the universe will
reside within black holes that have
sucked all of that energy in like all of
the matter that used to be me you haley
seinfeld martin luther king jr saturn
uranus the andromeda galaxy haley
steinfeld again all of that matter and
energy that ever existed will eventually
find itself swirling outside of the
extremely powerful gravitational pull of
a black hole a supermassive black hole
to be specific only to be trapped inside
of it until one day that black hole
finally dies and all the energy inside
of it explodes brighter than the biggest
supernova ever known to man like black
holes actually die in a massive flash of
light which is quite ironic this is
specifically where i believe he who
remains has situated himself in the mcu
in loki's season 1 finale and exactly
what dr strange and america chavez are
directly outside of as they get eaten
across time and space i believe that he
who remains built himself a castle on a
slowly crumbling mound of incredibly
dense vibranium in the middle of the
biggest supermassive black hole at the
end of time and has been manipulating
that black hole's gravity to control the
glowing energies of every single thing
that has ever existed in a neat little
bow that he calls the sacred timeline
like the sacred timeline is just the
energies of everything that ever existed
in everything that has ever happened a
sacred timeline that is now in complete
chaos in disarray ever since he who
remains decided to let his very control
over that supermassive black hole's
gravity go after having his last ever
conversation with loki one and loki two
spoiler alert loki two has a knife and i
believe that this specifically happened
during that weird moment when he who
remains tells the two that they've all
crossed this invisible something called
the threshold we just crossed
the threshold
wait did you see that did you see what
kang was doing kang was testing out the
gravity shift like the exact moment the
glowing energies of the sacred timeline
stopped being forced into a neat bow by
king's control of the black hole's
gravity thus allowing excessive timeline
branching to start to occur like he
remains did all that [ __ ] on purpose
because by crossing the ultimate black
hole's gravity threshold he who remains
had officially retired which is why he
starts being extremely candid and honest
with both loki's immediately afterwards
like he's just completely telling him
the truth because he doesn't have to lie
anymore because he won likely because
kang realized that the act of actively
conquering was a lot less boring than
being the winner whose conquering days
are long gone which is why he was
practically begging to be stabbed by
sylvie because homeboy knew that his
energy was about to be recycled within
those very energies going crazy right
outside the castle which is why i
believe the camera does a really clever
symbolic pan from his dead body to the
sacred timeline right outside his window
a window that i believe was cleverly
designed by the loki team to look like a
black hole with six balls of swirling
energy around it with each ball
representing an infinity stone energy
singularity that make up everything in
the mcu universe and keep it all
together for you see my nerd babies this
trippy doctor strange sequence in
multiverse madness isn't just a random
series of images meant to flex the
incredible artistic abilities of marvel
studios as cg partners who should
definitely be paid more because they're
amazing oh no because i believe what
these two are actually tumbling through
is the actual cosmic hierarchy of the
marvel cinematic universe let's go
through it together shall we alright so
america's first portal brings us to the
domain of multiple variants of the
living tribunal which caused a lot of
people familiar with the comics to
scratch their heads because as far as we
know the living tribunal's job is to
watch over the mcu's multiversal sacred
timeline to like one living tribunal for
the entire multiverse so like why are
there multiple living tribunals in this
shot well the reason for this is because
we're at the very top of the mcu
hierarchy with each living tribunal each
having authority over their own sacred
timelines presumably with their own tvas
like remember how the opening of the
loki finale opened with not one but two
supermassive black holes in frame i
believe that these are two separate
marvel multiverses each with their own
dedicated living tribunal that is
represented in this field of living
tribunals in multiverse of madness like
i believe that other black hole was a
whole nother multiverse like with a
whole bundle of universes possibly even
the fox x-men universe but we won't get
into that right now and it also explains
why right after they crash into a living
tribunal the outside of the sacred
timeline can be seen next because the
only person with more authority than the
person pulling the strings of the tva is
the living tribunal themselves so
basically we're going from living
tribunals to one specific living
tribunal who is watching this one
specific black hole with the sacred
timeline because that is their black
hole then after this we find doctor
strange and america chavez among a field
of jagged crystals going every which way
in the most chaotic manner possible
these crystals are what i believe to be
what each branching tendril of the
sacred timeline looks like and the very
reason why america's timeline hopping
punches have a crystal shattering effect
because as soon as these two progressed
into the sacred timeline after having
passed both the living tribunal and kang
supermassive black hole at the end of
time they started crashing through each
of these crystal tendrils of the
timeline and the actual multiverse
halving actually begins with the beehive
universe being the first universe these
two visit together because before that
they were just outside of the sacred
timeline they weren't even in the sacred
timeline yet before of course crashing
through different varied new york cities
along their way to earth 838 like i
strongly believe that each crystal wall
that they crash through is a crystal
tendril of the sacred timeline and that
america chavez's punches basically
shatter the crystal walls of the sacred
timeline at will which is pretty damn
cool but yeah this is the big loki
easter egg in doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness and i feel like
this is a big deal because it basically
shows that loki and disney plus shows
have a really big impact on the mcu
moving forward and that the actual
events of the loki finale are beginning
to find itself manifesting in the actual
big screen mcu so yeah very exciting but
anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
mastertainment on twitter if you want to
see me tweet some weird [ __ ] and really
fun theories but most importantly you
can follow new rockstars wherever we are
on social media and when you do on
youtube make sure you hit that
notification bell so you can get
notifications every time we upload a
video and of course do not forget to hit
up new rockstarsmerch.com to pick up our
newest latest obsession shirt inspired
by for love and thunder it's dope and
also don't forget to hit up our discord
if you want to continue the new
rockstars conversation but again thank
you guys for watching this video i love
you guys so much and i'll see you guys
next time bye
[Music]
so
[Music]